وصف نائم ورئيسي الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني
بطوله كاس العالم الجاريه في قطر بانها
البطوله الاكثر شمولا نظرا لتنوع الكبير
في الجماهير التي حضرت لمشاهدتها
صحيفه واشنطن بوستال الامريكيه الى تعرض
بلاده لهجوم وصفه بغير المسبوق ولم تعهده
الدول التي استضافت بطولات مماثله وقال ان
سلوك بعض وسائل الاعلام تجاه قطر كان
سلبيا ومخيبا للامال وفق تعبيره اضاف
الوزير القطري وانا افضل مكافاه لقطر هي
الطريقه التي استمتع بها المشجعون في
المونديال وبشان الانتقادات الموجهه
لبلاده قال الشيخ محمد عبد الرحمن الثاني
الى بلاده لا تدعي الكمال ولم تزعم ابدا
ان الظروف العمال المهاجرين لديها مثاليه
لكنها نفذت جميع الاصلاحات المرتبطه بهذا
الملف على مدارسنا 10 عاما الماضي الماضيه